[Music]
and sore loser news oh that's me all the
time always sore but not a loser
submitted by Arcadian oh ok 18 that's
one three hundred I thought I was on the
movie when the guys come and then to
like only brought 300 people to like
what do you guys do I'm an engineer I'm
a math teacher I'm a [ __ ] prostitute
you know like whoa we're all warriors no
he said he said Spartans what is your
vision yeah oh yeah um Wow she like
completely chests Arcadians I thought it
was Athenians no their Arcadians
Arcadians what do you do I like the
paint
I got Arcadia Mall I'm a parent what do
you do I'm a retail shop owner Murray
[Music]
[Laughter]
Saudis you're really super Carly that's
curly Ivana spot is currently sometimes
a guy called the cops after someone
found him during a basketball game pick
up game know if it's a pickup game it
could get kind of rough what does this
person look like tell me to say just say
it just say it what I feel like this
happened that like at LA Fitness on a
24-hour it depends on what the foul is
was there a flight after the foul to
because that happens a lot during pickup
games because people take you to serious
fight not fast why I don't play pickup
games anymore yeah cuz um I remember
this guy he he got the rebound very
aggressively and and I was standing
behind him and when he grabbed the ball
he [ __ ] swung his hand back and hit
my face and I knocked down and I got a
bloody nose from that and I was like
damn dude he's playing a little bit hard
for this is basketball so I could see
how like it could turn into straight
brawls or if someone could get severely
injured and everybody knows too if you
guys have ever played pickup games the
person
that gets into the fight the most is the
sorriest person on the basketball
because they get frustrated they suck
yeah and they're always the coach to
delight let's pick it up guys let's pick
it up Joe where's the defense it's a
pickup game the last time I played a
pickup game at all that Teresa said [ __ ]
you [ __ ] dude the last time I played a
pickup I played a pickup game with a 24
it was with Joseph Vincent and Jason
Chen and Jason Chen did the way he plays
basketball
I get his feeling no he's [ __ ]
serious about that yeah please a pickup
game like it's the [ __ ] playoffs and
he's trying to win a [ __ ] ring he
plays basketball as a pickup game
as if that's his last chance to get
taller two inches high we were [ __ ]
playing you know like it's a it's a fun
pickup game like on the court nobody's
good like we're just like we're just
average players Jase is actually pretty
damn good really good
no Joseph this is pretty decent too and
then we're just playing and just having
fun and this dude because I'll score not
him right and my jaws going on just
because I'm bigger you know I'm not that
slow either I'm a big dude but I'm not
slow yeah and so the guy literally comes
in as we're he's going down he dips his
shoulder and he shoulder checks me my
chin oh I fall down [ __ ] wet red and
this is his wallet XVI's with sort of
put you the [ __ ] wall just Bob Bob my
head started bleeding and I just walked
over to do it in the gut like dude I'm
so sorry and I looked at him I was like
it's okay man good bro you know
apologize it's all good I thought you
need his apology yeah Jason Chen looks
at me and he goes what happened was like
he said sorry what am I supposed to do
yeah he apologized that's it yeah yeah
but did I couldn't played him look at my
hand was shaking
can I just [ __ ] saw red yeah because
the guy [ __ ] dipped his shoulder and
knocked me in the face and I flew it was
bad but that's why I don't like playing
pickup games that people pick take it
too seriously yeah
like it's supposed to be fun pickup
gaming's is just like uh
use go when you program the random game
it's all strangers and there's just
there's not organized want to play on a
plane all threes fives and just match up
I understand aggressive basketball it's
supposed to be four that's like
aggressive Badman okay so here this
story this takes place in Virginia it
was at an LA Fitness I knew it it always
happens there it always he would take it
too far out LA Fitness boys at the gym
people are so [ __ ] annoying yeah
there's so [ __ ] serious I think like
the pre-workout didn't wear off after
the weights so they're carrying the
pre-workout energy been to the
basketball part entertain away too
seriously
yeah cuz when people get aggressive in a
non aggressive sport I just want to
fight
it kills the mood do you like even we're
playing games with our friends there's
always that one friend that get to tilt
it doesn't just like oh god I can't do
anything today and it's just like
because this is my question to them
right it's like it's like okay this is
what you lost the game right what
happened you go home you go back to work
at t-mobile you're okay ruins everyone's
mood it sucks yeah it's like you're not
gonna get it picked up by the NBA nobody
cares your girlfriend's not gonna [ __ ]
you anymore you're not gonna grow two
inches yeah like it's who cares dude
yeah I can't believe you said that Gina
Sullivan's Arden park that we got the
whip witness who said that apparently
any of these two guys they had like a
minor tussle between them and we just
tussin slap hands I think Claire so
there was a foul against player two so
player one missed a layup and then
aggressively ran through a screen
knocking player two to the ground he
kind of hit him in the face and that's
when that's that is aggressive that's
when the dude got up and he's like I'm
calling the police and everyone the new
[ __ ] imma tell mom
I'm gonna tell mom the hashtag yet today
what Oh [ __ ] basketball baby
hashtag basketball [ __ ] that's a
basketball layer here oh the name down
yeah so then everyone was just looking
around super confused cuz they thought
he was kidding but he actually stormed
out he went to the front desk
always [ __ ] stomping please send a
reply to the Bob Bob why easy so it's
got a you got valve you can't see it
lets see it got up he goes I'm calling
the cops
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's exactly my kind of straight up
gay he has a girlfriend I only want to
see Michael when Michael is about to
leave because I love the way he says bye
yeah never seen so much shoulder and
elbow in a way dude this is a Bob
there's no bones in his hands sometimes
I just take a shower have my hair wet so
he just dry it for me your stuff like
that
this will three went viral after this
tweet it said today for the first time
in my life I experienced someone calling
the police because they got fouled hard
in basketball so this guy with his arms
crossed us which was which one of those
calves arm sleeves he's [ __ ] serious
about he was the one I fouled him
they're both serious remember when I
told you tell me what they look like
tell me what it looks like
yeah well I'm hella confused he got why
people calves but a black person body
you think a Middle Eastern do their
reporting well I got the phone my
friends got a cops called on her from a
Middle Eastern guy too
cuz she in a nightclub or whatever yeah
so then everyone there so apparently two
guys do know each other and they've
known each other for a couple years and
you called the cops on she called the
cops on him is that cop in the back
laughing I would which is this guy oh
he's not gonna be laughing um so then
let me show you guys a video clip damn
here we go is the hardest aisle in
America but I knew every big koala for a
basketball foul before
now you got called for assault oh so now
I'm gonna show you guys a clip of the
body cam footage when he approached them
but I'll just show you about you're
gonna be ready shame in being a [ __ ]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just for today that's the only time you
can't even make a decision okay like
like from the bottom of my heart
honestly you're Marquess [ __ ] and I
hope someone says this video to you so
you can [ __ ] see all of us calling
you a little walk you know you know
what's even funnier is that his friend
that he's playing has to shoot her
sleeves on that's hilarious
why always shoot with one of them maybe
he's a sweaty dude he's using it as a
sweat guard it's it's compression for
your arm for when you shoot this I guess
it does the job but it's not oh it was
never originally for basketball it was
like a baseball thing or something and
then Ireson made a pause that was fun I
thought they thought they made him put
it on because of his tattoos cuz it was
so like
really have tattoos and NBS true I would
never if that if I was that dude I would
never be able to show my face anywhere
again because now you're known as a
little [ __ ] like if you trip and fall
you better not ever call the cops on the
sidewalk because the sidewalks being a
[ __ ] very easily tripped on the
sidewalk yeah damn Wow
I mean this is the bottom of my heart I
mean that's from the bottom of my heart
you're a [ __ ] little [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
I bet Julie you can [ __ ] you up
but you small Isaac can [ __ ] you up are
you gonna call the cops on him tears
literally the tiniest woman ever sitting
right next to you
[Laughter]
tiny if somebody coughs at you you'll
probably call it cuz guys this is
Mexican Armenian spit on me
[Music]
[Music]